the I think the important point is this
you look at all of these achievements
and many others what do they have in
common we were built without borders
built without borders and to put down
artificial orders in this d in each 21st
century is observed when we've achieved
particularly the 20th century in modern
times more modern times or candy the
woman right across the United Kingdom
for the benefit of everybody with
everybody feeling of Scott's don't leave
because we help please built on yuppers
Scottish mrs. greatness these
achievements just tune from the national
side you've left it quite late to make
this kind of positive sunshine any case
haven't you well I can assure you many
of us have been making it for a long
warm tight but you haven't been that
clearly heard it's mostly been about
warnings and fair hasn't it I've never a
believer believing the media but
negativity reporting so install disagree
with soil and all the rest of it taneous
to get you much more of a medium salon
there's something that's positive
without any reference you have
competitive on your formulas at all that
tends not to get important if you went
up to a conference in Aberdeen you would
have seen that the whole theme of the
weekend was about the sunshine strategy
about appealing to the better than
snakes of people to go for the
positivity about the UK and that has
been filtered through our campaign for
the following month so this has been
center of what we've done for available
taking